everyone and welcome to theories and
Thrones today we're talking all about
episode 5 of Game of Thrones final
season the bells i'm leanna gelareh from
Entertainment Tonight and I'm Mike Rizzo
from GameSpot we're excited to start
hearing about all of your fiery thoughts
on last night's episode because we have
a ton yes we have so much to discuss I'm
burning with rage just like Danny as
always before we get started this is an
after show so you shouldn't be here
unless you've watched the episode
because we're after the show because
we're getting into spoilers all the
spoilers spoilers there's so many so
many finally so many finally I'm so
excited that we actually have so much to
discuss right now what did you guys
think we're gonna be discussing all the
deaths thankfully there were a lot this
time that sounds really much sounds so
morbid but I was really excited
characters died plus we're gonna be
sharing an exclusive interview with the
stars revealing how they really feel
about their on-screen fate Mike how did
you feel about this episode I want to
hear everybody's thoughts for sure but
but for me personally I thought that
this episode would have been a 10 out of
10 like it was an incredible spectacle
it was well directed it was brutal and
dark and terrifying if if if it had been
preceded by two seasons or even three
seasons of like the Game of Thrones that
that we used to have that that's well
written and they built up to these
moments properly it would have been
incredible as it is to me it didn't it
didn't feel owned and we're gonna talk
about a lot of it as an episode as a
whole I enjoyed watching it I loved that
I could see all the battles so shout out
to John for saying actually we're gonna
attack at dawn yeah the real hero of the
episode we're already starting getting
so many of your comments Kristy cease
says what is the point of Jamie's arc if
he wasn't gonna find some kind of
redemption we're gonna get in and the
end says I predict that John will be the
one to kill Danny after everything he's
seen and everything she's done oh I have
some theories about that too
a lot of theories about that but so why
don't we dive into the biggest question
of the episode which is who died who
died everyone these are the deaths that
I wanted yes in in episode 3 because
this felt like a battle mistakes kicking
us off Lord Varys
Oh Varys you little spider of Westeros
you thought that you could keep creeping
around the master for the master of
whispers he was pretty loud about his
like big old treason that he was that he
was doing like Ferris went around the
last two episodes being like I'm
thinking about doing some treason do you
want to hear about it you want to hear
about my treason it was very unfair
alike but I think that this show is at
its best when bad decisions have
consequences and his bad decision had
consequences
I loved the brief interaction that we
had between tyrion and varys before he
died where tyrion owned up to and is
like hey it was me that sentenced you to
die I kind of tipped us off to the Queen
but to be fair I warned you yeah and it
turns even more bittersweet when we
realized by the end of the episode that
Varys was right of course varistors
right all these little things you know
compound to cause Danny to do what she
did exactly you can't point to any one
thing but bears betraying her definitely
added to it yeah like a self-fulfilling
exactly very satisfying death which led
to then Danny going crazy and then you
need to say r.i.p to the hundreds of
thousands of citizens of King's Landing
how dare next is the city of King's
Landing yes and most of the people who
live there it seems like I mean this was
this was brutal and I think the smartest
thing they did is to have us on the
ground in King's Landing not just with
John yeah he's in the thick of battle
but with Arya eventually is it was so
great to see that even though she's this
great assassin assassin she's been beat
she's been battered it's hard to escape
the destruction as like John is trying
to get through it all yeah it's
terrifying and you really got to see the
first-hand experience of what it's like
having a dragon attack he was so
effectively shot and edited and put
together yeah and as much as like in
episode 3 her portions of that episode
felt like a like a horror movie
right where she was sneaking around and
as much as that didn't work for me her
parts of this episode being a disaster
film yeah Dave work anywhere she's
there's destruction all around her and
all she's trying to do is
survive maybe help a few other people
survive when she failed at and it was
just it was gruesome let's talk about
someone who didn't survive and that's
you're on Greyjoy
thank God thank God he was gone okay
let's talk about the fact that he noped
off his boat just like Theon did a
couple seasons ago the plot armor
remains so I mean it and he just so
happened to wash up on the secret shores
of King's Landing as Jaime Lannister
exactly where Jaime is it's it's way too
convenient yeah it is poetic yes its
cinematic yes and overall I was just
happy to see him get stabbed through the
spine the fact that you're on yes oh and
that cute it up perfectly trying to
refer to himself as a king was so
obnoxious
on what grounds yeah and since when this
is not a thing that like is he the king
of the Iron Islands so nobody bent the
knee to Cersei right so I don't know it
was like it was like it was glimmers of
book your honor that was a very
different character and and here he's
just a homicidal maniac who loves to
laugh really loud but hey he slept with
the Queen and he made sure that we knew
it
of course okay that's what matters here
on what matters to Mike a Clegane bull
but we've got to say that in the middle
of Clegane bowl that means that it led
to the death of the Hound and the
mountain so r.i.p these brothers and
Qyburn let's not forget sorry I know
that we did forget about Qyburn I mean
but at the same time like by Qyburn I
enjoy I enjoyed I enjoyed their death a
lot and we are going to talk about
Clegane is fully breaking down club a
clicking a little but let's talk about
it a little bit right now see these
brothers go off with each other we see
the mountain without his helmet on it
was such it was such a good scene it was
I loved it and it was it was more
importantly it was a good death for both
of them because the mountain deserved it
obviously but then for the Hound like to
take him down and sacrificing himself
yeah and falling into this you know
storm of fire is so it's such a good
finality for him and and and not that
he's overcome his fear of fire but he's
accepted his fate yeah I have more
thoughts on this but we will come back
to it we talked about clicking ball next
up we have to say
our IP to the sister and brother who
loved each other the my skin crawl
[Laughter]
man you got to talk about the fact that
Jaime I I was expecting so much more
from this death and I know that a lot of
fans were really upset to see Cersei get
such a yeah so Aneesa Abraham says
Cersei should have had a more brutal
death Danny should have jerk arist her
ass and I agree I would have loved to
have seen it was Danny be the one to
take downstairs he seemed like by the
end sir she was so defeated and then to
be taken out by this storm of rubble as
she's in her brother's arms does that
count as Jaime killing her right so this
this we've talked about it it kind of in
a way like Game of Thrones is very good
at presenting as a prophecy or
prediction and fulfilling it in some
unexpected way or in a way that can be
interpreted in multiple different ways
and so in a way the valonqar the little
brother theory Jaime led her down there
to her death yeah and at it was at
Tyrians behest right Tyrion sent them
down there so in a way they were both
responsible although as we did not
predict neither of them actually meant
to but I felt like this series has given
us so many good deaths of villains like
Tywin dying on the toilet and the most
under I undignified way possible I love
that Joffrey choking to death his own
wedding like those moments felt so
cathartic it's fine I thought it was it
it was disappointing but also kind of
fitting that we didn't get that death
for Cersei one of the things that I did
love about Circe's death is I read a
comment where it's like she was crushed
by all of the choices that she made that
led her to this point yes she did
everything to fight for the survival of
her house and did everything to fight
for the survival of her relationship
with her brother / lover and the fact
that they died in each other's arms as
weird as it is I'm not too mad about it
a lot of the fans might not be too
pleased with Jamie's death yeah what
about Jaime so what do you think about
about the way that he ultimately back
slid and kind of became this I I like it
because for me it goes back to obviously
you want a good character arc but it
goes back to people don't change
yeah it's it fell
it felt very realistic it doesn't feel
like that here Ozark that everyone
wanted where he he did have a great
overcoming of the name Kingslayer and
and really proving himself he did quite
a bit about the course of the series and
that's why people are upset right is
that ultimately his character growth
meant nothing for his for his ultimate
fate yeah for his ending he he back slid
and became he went back to his sister
and died with her and I fully understand
why I'm disappointed in that yeah for
sure I don't think that it doesn't make
sense yeah I think that it does make
sense the problem for me is that it's
just so cynical
it's this it's this cynical nihilistic
worldview that and it fits with Danny to
that you can't escape your your worst
instincts the worst parts of your family
and yourself yeah that sucks
I I get it but it's such you might not
be too happy with Jaime's death and the
fans might not be too happy but guess
who is happy actor Nikolaj copy with
Jamie's fate take a look at what he told
me when I sat down with him at the
junket feel very true to the to this
show and to this to the character so
wasn't if I win I'll bring your head to
Cersei Sirkin kisser one last time so
what was your initial reaction when you
read your last script I can say
something I can say I was I was very
excited I'm very happy for the way that
my character is gonna end up on Game of
Thrones I got introduced a little bit
later in season six so I honestly I was
like why would you introduce a character
in season six and then killing season
seven or beginning of season eight so
I'm very happy
but I got you I'm the man who kills
Jamie Lannister
talk to me about your reaction when you
read the script for your final episode
um a wife I was I was really pleased
with that just look at me I mean I
thought they did an amazing job overall
with every with the whole with the whole
season but but with Jamie also just
really yeah it made sense and he it
wasn't it was very in them feel very
true to the to this show and to this to
the character so wasn't happy
[Music]
feel very true to the let's keep the
conversation going with the other big
moments of the episode with oMG geo team
which is my favorite segment of it all
first up Mike's favorite moment
cleganebowl the hype was real I just
like I've had a lot of complaints this
season as anybody who's been watching
this show you know knows but like you're
so excited I was it was so like my
friend of mine made these and brought
them over and we had a bunch of people
over and watched it yeah and like it's
the most fun I've had watching Game of
Thrones in years yes and I can't imagine
this going down in a more perfect way
what did you think about the fact that
the mountain went back to his classic
move of squishing the life out of his
eyeballs
yeah and dashing people's brains against
walls like when he killed Qyburn like if
there was any doubt about whether the
mountain is still the mountain yeah it
that was dashed you know along with KY
burns face because that's his classic
move that he does to you know babies
during Robert's rebellion that's that
that's that's the move and so he - his
Chi burns head and that was when the
hype became real and we just started
yelling and cheering and it was I mean
what did you think exactly he kept
stabbing him over and over again I was
like there's got to be a weakness and
then I thought when he finally got him
in the head I'm like oh it's like
walking dead you just gotta get him once
on the head and then they're done but no
he kept pushing so if it wasn't the Lord
of Light that brought the mountain back
I don't know what the heck Chiron was
doing and how he actually pulled this
off yeah I mean he was just like
probably never get answered no I and
that's one of the things that bothers me
like I like to gamble but the whole time
I was just thinking I'm like dear God
when is he actually going to die he was
like the Energizer Bunny from hell
that's fair and there's there's a
question to be asked about did the
mountain have a weakness was it fine
yeah right was it dragonglass does he is
he the same rules as the White Walkers
and the white stabbed a thing sir was I
and then how was he stopping
is it not only did it look like a video
game boss fight like it looked like
resident evil or like a Mortal Kombat
cutscene to me but I also would
apparently play by the same rules
because like you can shoot video game
bosses in the head and it usually
doesn't kill them but just the two of
them standing there on that staircase
I'm gonna keep this on by them yeah just
the two of them standing there on that
staircase with the city in the
background drogon flying by spewing fire
intercutting between arya being on the
ground as well it was ten out of ten
I loved it was watching again it was up
to the height let's put it this way it
was way more entertaining than this
year's Superbowl yeah there's more
entertainment a lot of things anymore I
think that was the I think that was the
best seen since the Sept of Baelor
explosion in season 6 big words but I
liked it
um one of the things that I'm not quite
sure if I liked moving on is let's meet
Mad Queen Danny
yeah because sure she's officially lost
it and yes this has been foreshadowed
yes we know her family history but the
bells are ringing she clearly is hearing
them she knows that the city has
surrendered and she just goes full-on
droga on attack yeah so this is this is
the main reason why this episode doesn't
work for me okay and I and she's looking
at her home yeah so the so David and Dan
said you know the showrunner said in the
post episode you know featurette this is
the moment she looks at the red cape
which her family built 300 years ago
represents everything that was taken
away from her and this is the moment
when it gets they said it gets personal
for her it's been a personal this whole
time I call BS on that if it was
personal she would have flown to the red
cape and Santa Rosa Jersey life yes not
personal for her to go street-by-street
young King's Landing and murder a
hundred thousand innocent people I felt
like it was like Google Maps just
lighting up the way of being like here's
Jay over here and here's the street over
here I felt terribly for these citizens
because we actually got to see their
fear we got to see there's nothing you
can do it was so effective
I get that she snapped and I get that
she was so upset that Cersei killed in a
Sunday last episode and and she's trying
to prove to them that I'm not the
ruthless one it's your queen who is
if you see from Tyrion space he's like
what on earth are you doing right I mean
I get that she snapped I don't get why
she snapped
you know Jorah died miss sandy died
heard a couple of her dragons died Jon
you know has a better claim and she
feels insecure about that but like the
the Mad King Aerys her father who the
comparison has been made endlessly you
know they always say when a Targaryen is
born is born the gods flip a coin but no
one ever said they'd flip a switch like
the Mad King went mad over many years
and was initially early in his reign was
a kind generous ruler you could counter
that Dany has been going mad this whole
time as it's been leading her more and
more to this point I just don't I I
totally get what you're saying and and
and it's hard to do the juxtaposition of
her dad when we didn't really see his
his reign we just have heard of it and
the and the book readers of course you
have a little bit more but my whole
thing with Dany is why all the innocent
people if you're so pissed at Cersei fly
directly to the red keyboard you've been
already destroyed the Scorpions kill the
soldiers who surrendered that would be
evil enough yes
right and out but that would make sense
yeah the people who stood against her
these bystanders have nothing to do with
it and they're just in two truncated
shorten seasons yeah
there just has not been enough build-up
yeah to turn her from the breaker of
chains the freer of slaves the mother to
the small folk and the common people
into this absolute genocide 'el maniac
who's killing hundreds of thousands of
people for no purpose and Lords be
completely agrees with you they're right
why kill all those innocent people oh so
mad I liked her in the beginning of Game
of Thrones that stopped liking her when
she got obsessed with wanting power and
Christie see Elsa said Danny wants
vengeance from a Sunday ragle etc it's
not insanity but recklessness and
revenge I think she wanted I think if
she wanted vengeance yeah knew where to
fly she could she was looking at the red
cape she just goes directly there the
people responsible for this are there
and she's not an idiot she knows that I
don't think it's vengeance I think it I
think the show is trying to sell it as
insanity because you know something
snaps yeah and it's insane
for her to burn King's Landing to the
ground street-by-street just zigzag for
an hour and it was hard to watch Danny
may be mad but you know what arias
because let's bring into our next
section with your transition are you
super pissed yes yes yes she is
this was and I'm gonna go on my little
RAM right now please this was my
favorite moment of the episode as
difficult as it was and as as tedious in
in almost a way of every time arya kept
getting knocked down it was so important
to see her be in the midst of these
streets see her having the fire rain
down on her when we almost lost her that
one time when she jumped around the
corner yeah watching through her eyes as
she realizes all of the destruction and
the chaos that Danny has caused it has
just further cemented it in her mind
that this is not the person who needs to
lead them yeah John would never do this
and as much as I'm not like let's go
team John at this point okay right
John's been pretty incompetent but he
has not done a genocide exactly exactly
in Inzaghi fifty says the scenes at the
end with aria were wonderful throwback
to the scared little girl in King's
Landing after Ned's execution I think
that's a really good point and you and I
were talking about this before we got
started it was so refreshing to see when
Arya went there she was gonna kill
Cersei she was determined she's got her
assassin knowledge and as soon as the
world starts crumbling around her it
takes Sandra to look at her and be like
you don't have to do that it was such a
it was such a good moment and and yeah
she chose life she chose to not do that
I think as nihilistic and cynical as
most of this episode and it's the final
it's the second or last episode so so
most this episode and thus most of the
series the theme seems to be you know
it's it's human nature this this descent
into chaos and succumbing to our worst
instincts and our worst traits as people
and she has become the one character
because she's she swung so far in the
other yeah her story got so dark and she
just became this unfeeling agent of
murder yeah and she has now come back to
the light it's like she's she snapped
out of it it's like
had to see all this death and
destruction what she used to relish it
but seeing that even though she's this
amazing assassin that she was able to
get knocked down so many times it just
was a good dose of reality that I think
that she really needed and I think her
coming back to the light and realizing
that you know she would rather she would
rather live yeah then get her revenge
which is ultimately petty I mean sirs
he's gonna die regardless of whether
you're there and this goes back to the
theories right of what is already gonna
do now yeah well why don't we take a
look at the trailer for the series
finale of Game of Thrones which gives us
a little bit I didn't I know let's take
a look
[Music]
[Applause]
sidenote
how are there so many unsullied soldier
ocular I do not understand where have
they been the stakes of various battles
and events and the logistics of how all
these armies are still apparently out
yeah there you go
I don't I don't understand the
continuity of how many forces anyone has
I don't think I'm supposed to I don't
think I think it does matter at this
point I think the only thing that we
were supposed to see in that trailer is
that aria is not yeah who he is I think
it's I think it's a loss that we don't
get those logistics anymore in this show
and it's one of the casualties of
getting these trunking it reminds me of
like time travel in the show they're
just like yeah just don't think about it
too much I'm like I think about it a lot
Kenzie Cain says Aria won't kill Danny
the showrunners loved John too much not
to let him do it since he didn't get the
night king I completely agree with you
Kenzi I understand that some people like
Mike would say that it fulfills the
prophecy of the green ice yeah yeah to
me like the Melisandre like brown eyes
blue eyes green eyes thing is like a
very obvious prediction in retrospect
and it's the kind of thing that I think
they have put so much focus on it that
they'll probably pay it off I also think
that it it it's a beautiful fulfillment
of arias character arc because everybody
who's think about the people the names
on her list up until this point right
Gregor and Cersei yes they're evil
they're bad guys yeah exactly
okay but not everybody on that list was
evil right Noah Sondre they were the
people who betrayed her Darian the hound
these were petty vendetta's and she
didn't care about who was good and who
was bad and if she kills Danny in the
next episode it's not because of a
personal vendetta she doesn't really
have any personal stake in this it will
be for the greater good because she saw
the destruction firsthand and she'll
know that it's the right thing to do so
it would be the first time that she used
her powers for something other than a
personal vendetta and I think it would
be good would I like Arya to do it yes
do I think that we'll get to give her
like it's like collecting pokemon cards
is she gonna get to have two of the
biggest one it's another kill yeah if
she gets another giant kill she got the
night King and
think working backwards you know the
showrunners had set in the inside the
episode we had it planned by three years
ago the REO was gonna kill the necking
because it's unexpected right and the
expected thing was to have John be the
one to kill the night king so I think
that they wanted to save John killing
Danny and so they're like okay well none
who's gonna kill the knight came because
that person can't have two I I'm not
sure that's
I mean if Danny even guys like it's not
definitely not guaranteed I mean there's
a version of this where she executes
Tyrion and John next episode and I mean
let's which leads us to our our next
question or actually no we're gonna go
into our graphics of questions comments
and theories from you guys as we fully
dive into all of this
the first question that we have is what
is John gonna do next because that's
exactly what we need to start talking
about what is John gonna do yeah I don't
I honestly don't know yeah that's like I
know it's still Game of Thrones because
I still don't really have any idea
what's gonna happen we're he's nice yeah
which is nice um let's talk about the
scene before all this chaos and fire and
blood was spilled to win John and Danny
were having their lives their last
fireside incestual love central make out
says yeah and and I will point out that
John is the one that pulled away first
because it's clear that he cannot get
over the fact that that says aunt but um
she was furious with him for telling
Sansa but let's be real like he's not
going to not tell them I don't know I
never thought that that was a perfect
situation is beyond me again it's like
these small decisions that have
compounded yeah sort of to turn her and
I I do think that it was rushed and that
she turned to evil too quickly but there
are so many moments over the past you
know five episodes that we can point to
that are just like this where John has
perfectly valid reasons why he's acting
the way he's acting and why he's doing
this
and why he rejects her why he can't you
know love her yeah even though she is
his queen and this is one of the things
that that sets her on this path what I
wish is that we had actually heard in
John's own words why like this is what's
missing from the books right where the
books are characters perspectives we
have in their heads we understand what
they're thinking and feeling I don't
understand like is it real
as simple as Johnny's just roast out by
incest no it's no like I've made this
point before but it wasn't that long ago
in the show's history it was it was less
than two decades ago that Aerys
Targaryen was king he was married to his
sister and in that was just how the
Targaryens did it it was just pretty
much accepted and and what I feel the
pivotal scene that has been missing from
Johnny Danny's story is a conversation
where they sit down and they go look
yeah Targaryen 's have traditionally
married within their own family this
would make sense and then John has to go
I just can't I can't accept it maybe
only heard from you yes that in the
finale because it really is see that
Tyrion is one who has just like you
really been pushing the fact that these
two people should rule together that he
is the ice that will balance out her
fire and maybe can rein her in but at
this point I'm worried that Dany has
gone too far
she's absolutely she of course but I'm
worried that like they've expressed
their I love yous but I don't think you
can love her through this I don't think
that they still have that chance and I
think she's gonna look at him and be
like fine we have a comment from arena
black who says John realized his mistake
too late I mean fair yeah the whole
situation is just chaotic and I have no
idea what's gonna happen in the series
finale but that's what actually makes me
excited and it's good like he realized
his mistake too late and they you know
there were horrifying tragic
consequences and that's you know that's
the game of Thrones
that I love yeah it's sad it messes me
up inside but any last thoughts as we
finish talking about this episode and as
we go into the series finale
well arena black asks will Dany execute
Sansa for treason
I think if Danny gets the chance she's
certainly at this point she's just gonna
blink and end up back in Winterfell real
quickly I mean you can fly there on her
dragon and that's true that's true
I think if Danny gets a chance she'll
execute anyway I've been saying it this
whole time in my head
Sansa for the Iron Throne all right so
for the Iron Throne let me know it's who
I'm voting there's a real possibility
that that you know even if they kill
Danny that that John you know doesn't
make the obvious choice John just walks
away maybe he goes and lives up north
but torment and ghost I am curious to
know reunited too soon he's not gonna
get those past which led me though to my
last thought which is do you think we're
gonna see Sam again do you think we're
gonna see Tommen do you think we're
gonna see Brienne see tormund I don't
know I think he's good by which one I
think he's gone what about brand Oh do
you think I mean like bran had nothing
to do well to me nothing his character
arc and the purpose of bran is one of
the great losses of the show because
they totally dropped the ball I would
love if there was a big Mike drop moment
where brand reveals something in his
weird little ominous voice that ties all
of this together a brand not have warned
them about this bran can see the future
brand knows what's gonna happen most of
his time in the past he really didn't
care he could not muster the energy to
care about hundreds of thousands of
people getting melted no come on dude he
could not they made him to power votes
like in Harry Potter when they
introduced time travel and then in you
know book 5 or whatever they have to
have all of the time Turner's destroyed
or else it ruins the entire series it's
like bran was too powerful bran is the
time Turner games ruin the play in
London we have a lot to talk about
ok guys we're gonna end it there thank
you so much for tuning into today's
episode and I'm so excited to tell you
that you need to join us for a super
special theories and Thrones immediately
after the Game of Thrones series finale
on Sunday May 19th I'm excited that we
don't have to get up as early but we are
going to be hot up on adrenaline and
lots and lots of coffee yes even though
it's Sunday night this is just how we
rollin out we'd love for you to join us
as we break down the final episode of
Game of Thrones and as always we're
going to include your comments your
thoughts and your theories as soon as
you're done watching the episode come to
et tu tu page we're gonna be breaking it
all down we cannot wait to hear what you
have to think you can tweet us your
thoughts anytime you like thanks again
for watching theories and Thrones we'll
see you Sunday night right
[Music]
you